12h01 faux avec alec castonguay
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rebonjour pour ceux qui ne les écoute à
la radio comme d'habitude des bons jours
à ce qu'ils se joignent à nous sur le
site internet de radio canada on est
également diffusé sur facebook et sur
youtube si je salue également ceux qui
sont ici en personne avec nous on est
sur la troisième sur la passerelle au
troisième étage de la nouvelle maison de
radio-canada y en a qui ont pris un
moment dans leur peau ou aux dîners pour
venir nous écouter ça explique un peu le
bruits d'ambiance que vous allez
peut-être entendre nous allons consacrer
les 50 prochaines minutes à la
couverture du conflit en ukraine avec
nos journalistes céline galipeau chef
d'antenne principal du téléjournal et
amar altéré sco correspondante à moscou
du moins était correspondante à moscou
jusqu'à ce que la russie redonne la
fermeture du bureau de radio canada un
peu plus tôt cette semaine on verra ce
que l'avenir réservé aux camarades
d'ailleurs vous avez été nombreux par
dizaines presque même une centaine de
personnes à nous envoyer vos questions
pour céline pour tamara depuis le début
de la semaine fut d'ailleurs continuer à
nous écrire en direct je vais essayer
d'ajouter quelques questions si c'est
possible dans les prochaines heures
alors on s'installe confortablement et
on commence tout de suite après ce petit
montage sonore
prenez les chez au premier speed dial
bonsoir mesdames messieurs les choses
évoluent très vite en ukraine ce qu'on
redoutait est en train de se produire
vladimir poutine vient de déclarer la
guerre à l'ukraine alors on vous
retrouve tamara vladimir poutine passe
donc de la parole aux actes c'est un
discours qui est apparue par surprise
comme vous dit à la télévision russe et
qui de toute évidence a été pré
enregistrée par ce qu'est le rôle en
boucle et dans lequel il annonce aux
russes est en fait à la planète entière
que la russie a entrepris j'ai pris des
notes une opération militaire dans le
donbass on est à belgorod devant un feu
de circulation qui le dernier avant la
frontière de l'ukraine et on est à
seulement 50 km de ratcliffe qui est la
deuxième ville d'ukraine et qui a été le
théâtre aujourd'hui
d'intenses bombardements
notre chef d'antenne céline galipeau
vient d'arriver en ukraine elle hissera
au reportage pendant deux semaines
céline on vous retrouve à kiev vous
savez ça fait longtemps qu'on court
cette guerre de loin on a vu tout on
voit toutes ces images à la télévision
comme tout le monde est là de se
retrouver ici en arrivant dans la
capitale on l'a vu beaucoup de deux
maisons détruites parce que les combats
ont été extrêmement durs ici dans la
région de kiev donc il ya une espèce de
réalité on voit de cette guerre de son
impact aussi sur les ukrainiens donc on
va essayer de couvrir du mieux qu'on
peut ce conflit pour vous
bonjour céline bonjour tamara bonjour
les clivages jours c'est beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et de
répondre aux questions de nos auditeurs
c'est fort apprécié je vous observé
céline quand vous avez entendu les
premières paroles qui dans le fond
déclaré ce conflit ouvert vous avez un
peu les larmes aux yeux ça vous rappelle
quelque chose de oui parce que on peut
se préparer à cet événement là mais en
même temps on n'y croyait pas pour
personne la planète n'y croyais pas et
tout à coup c'est arrivé brutalement le
24 février puis c'est un moment c'est
assez marquante parce que on se disait
bon ça peut-être que ça va arriver mais
il osera pas vladimir poutine n'osera
pas et là maintenant on se retrouve
trois mois plus tard et on voit tout ce
qui s'est passé depuis ce que vous
saviez déjà ce moment là que vous
vouliez aller sur le terrain que vous
souhaitiez aller en ukraine
bon c'est une question délicate la chef
d'antenne du téléjournal parce que mon
rôle premier c'est bien sûr d'être à
l'animation de ce bulletin là mais c'est
vrai que quand il se passe quelque chose
d'important comme ça on a toujours comme
journaliste a envie d'y aller donc oui
c'est vrai que j'ai je m'étais
manifester parce que mais évidemment on
avait des grandes correspondante sur le
terrain donc il n'y avait pas il n'y
avait pas de place à ce moment-là mais
j'avais dit que ça m'intéressait déjà
les mouettes à m'arrêter là marie-eve
bédard zettel a
effectivement tamar on s'est beaucoup
parlé vous et moi en ondes à midi un fou
dans les semaines précédant ce conflit
là on analysait les déplacements trop
vous premier à la frontière avec
l'ukraine mais on se parle on on sentait
pas ni vous ni moi que c'était quelque
chose qui se prépare est d'aussi intense
le l'invasion totale de notre pays on se
dit bon est ce que vraiment ça va avoir
lieu quelle a été votre première
réaction dans la nuit quand vous avez
compris que finalement ça y était et que
la guerre était déclarée l'extrait
convient d'entendre rouge je paraphrase
l'admirent poutine en russe ça a été le
moment où on a compris puis c'était je
racontais la journée qu'on avait vécu
nous on était dans une passe et nos
journées près de la frontière a essayé
d'espionner les troupes russes parce
qu'on n'avait pas le droit de les filmer
on voyait à se cacher même plus on les
voyait en avait dix antennes partout au
dépanneur à l'épicerie les villages
étaient envahis de soldats mais on se
retirait à une centaine de kilomètres à
rostov sur le don pour dormir et ce soir
là c'était une journée sacrée encore en
russie c'est le jour du défenseur de la
patrie séjour des soldats les autres le
jour des hommes on célèbre les soldats
ok donc à minuit sur le même balcon où
j'ai fait ce direct là avec ces lignes
avait des feux d'artifice et l a fait
et on savait on nous avait dit
surveiller 4 heures du matin alors de
l'ukraine c'est là que ça va mais tu es
super motivation est donc c'était
surréel de voir les gens se promenaient
des potes pop corn c'est très festif et
il est re s'adorent les feux d'artifice
quand on habite en russie en a partout
pour toutes les occasions les gens
sortent même si fait froid et les
regarde il y avait une ambiance de fête
une ambiance de fête à quelques
kilomètres de là où on allait attaquer
et comme de fait à quatre heures nous on
est restés debout on a commandé à manger
on n'est pas couché et poutine
apparaître comme ça la télévision et ça
roulait en boucle et et avec des termes
en russe j'avais besoin qu'on m'aide à
interpréter exactement parce que c'est
un discours qui va devenir historique on
le sent on le sent sur le moment et le
moment où j'étais en ondes avec céline
et je pense que c'était le téléjournal
quatre heures pile du matin avec marie
ève bédard on savait qu'il était en
train d'attaquer le donbass mais j'ai
entendu un coup accueilli hier était une
grosse surprise et la loi ça m'a coupé
la parole beau coupé la parole mais
samassa m'a bouleversée a bouleversé
toute l'équipe parce qu'on se disait ok
ça sera pas juste mario paul ça sera pas
juste le donbass on vient de basculer
dans un autre univers en europe ont pris
l'ampleur de ce que ça allait être comme
moi et avec avec des frissons et les
choses quand même qui skie bombe qu'ils
osent bombardé kiev dès le premier soir
c'était tout un signal en fait qu'on en
voyait absolument hors de question de
nadim mograbi de montréal qui voulait
savoir tamara comment dans ce contexte
là on fait la conciliation travail
famille est ce que vous vous êtes en
nombre pensent évidemment votre métier
mais vous avez des enfants vous avez un
conjoint qui est en russie est ce qu'à
ce moment là vous vous dites bon je vais
devoir quitter qu'on pense à ce moment
là sur le moment on pense pas ça on est
tellement focus sur notre travail sur ce
qu'on veut dire on comprend aussi la
portée de ce qui se passe de ce qu'on
veut dire on évacue les pensées c'est
pas secondaire c'est primordial pour ma
vie à moi ma famille mais sur le moment
on n'y pense pas
la conciliation travail famille elle
n'est pas facile on va pas se mentir
mais elle est faisable on sur un projet
familial aller en russie moi je dois
répéter parce que les gens mais crée
souvent bravo pour votre courage moi
j'ai jamais été en danger mon intégrité
physique à part peut-être le risque d'un
drone ukrainien qui frappe par miracle
hôtel où on est ou peut-être un incident
provoqué par la russie ce qui a déjà été
fait en tchétchénie son yo pensez mais
moi j'étais pas en danger donc ce n'est
pas un stress pour ma famille qui était
à moscou d'avoir un stress pour mais pas
trop non plus quoique on s'expose et
nous notre risque c'est de se faire
arrêter par le fsb qui nous suivait
partout se faire arrêter par contourner
les troupes mais je dois le dire c'est
peut-être cliché mais j'ai un mari
extraordinaire qui est là avec moi et
qui partagent cette aventure-là et mais
on peut pas sur le moment pensé à ça on
est on est très dévoué à ce qu'on voit
et comment le raconter avec le plus de
précision possible c'est le mien auteurs
georges et marveaux j'espère que je le
prononce correctement qui nous
demandaient pourquoi et journal et
sentent le besoin de se déplacer dans
des lieux où ça va mal où il ya des
conflits où on met notre vie en danger
il faisait référence à la journaliste
d'al jazeera qui est morte mais pas très
longtemps cisjordanie en zinc ouvrait
une opération presque de routine de
l'armée israélienne qui elle est décédée
pourquoi au confesseur dans le fond
parce que c'est l'essence même de notre
métier d'être sur le terrain quand il se
passe quelque chose donc cette
journaliste extrêmement courageuse elle
vivait sur place ça faisait des années
qu'elle couvrait ce conflit et les
palestiniens avaient beaucoup de respect
pour elle parce qu'elle le faisait au
péril de vie et cette fois là on a vu
les images de ce de la façon dont elle a
été tuée et sobre il ya une enquête
l'israël dit que ça ne l'est pas du côté
israélien mais on verra mais on a envie
d'être sur le terrain pour voir quoi
parce que comme je l'expliquais un petit
peu c'est c'est bien de découvrir cette
guerre de loin on la comprend parce que
surtout une guerre comme celle là qui se
passe pratiquement en direct avec
beaucoup de possibilités de faire des
entrevues et c'est donc on peut couvrir
d'ici et on peut comprendre de façon
assez intellectuelle ce qui se passe sur
le terrain vous le fait tous les jours
on analyse ce conflit là mais
c'est tout autre chose d'arriver sur le
terrain et de le voir soi-même et de
faire les entrevues avec les gens sur le
terrain de découvrir soi-même ce qui
s'est passé ou pas dans un endroit et je
pense que là on ya une compréhension
plus émotive de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain je pense que ça nous permet de
mieux raconter mais c'est c'est toujours
comme ça on se disait souvent quand on
venait d'un conflit c'est drôle parce
qu'on se retrouvait sur des routes tout
le monde quitte et puis nous on voulait
absolument rentrer dans des états c'est
particulier mais je pense que c'est le
métier quoi on a besoin de faire ce dont
on a besoin de faire ça même quand on
fait autre chose comme moi maintenant
j'ai toujours besoin où j'ai toujours
envie disons c'est pas toujours possible
mais j'ai toujours envie d'aller voir
moi-même oui on reste profondément
journalistes même si on est
effectivement animatrice ou chef
d'antenne je suis sûr que même si vous
ressentez la même chose mais c'est pas
mal à me dire on sent tellement vivant
aussi quand on est sur le terrain et
notre chauve est vraiment une autre
facette du métier complètement puis
comme chef d'antenne céline va devoir
parler de cette guerre pendant des mois
et des années sa connexion sur le
terrain avec cela la rend beaucoup plus
sensible à ce que les journalistes
vivent aussi puisque ça va occuper
l'ailé l'actualité pendant encore des
mois et des animations
céline cette fois-ci vous êtes si
accompagné par un conseiller en sécurité
sur le terrain en ukraine n'ont pas un
garde du corps le pot quelqu'un qui vous
protège mais quelqu'un qui vous
conseillent commence à changer votre
travail votre travail à quoi il servait
ce conseiller là j'avoue mais quelle
c'est la première fois et même travail
qu'un compte un consultant en sécurité
je pense que d'autres collègues l'ont
vécu avant moi
parce que c'est relativement récent je
pense que au départ j'étais très ça
m'inquiétait un peu parce que je me
disais est ce que nos déplacements à ce
que le choix de nos sujets va dépendre
maintenant de la sécurité et non pas de
l'évaluation que moi je peux en faire
selon mes instincts de journalisme et
les connaissances que j'ai du terrain
alors
cette personne là en fait je les
trouvais finalement très très utile
lester très rassurant d'avoir quelqu'un
comme ça parce que quand on le devait à
se déplacer par exemple quand il fallait
aller disons à l'aporie déjà on a décidé
d'aller dans le sud du pays il fallait
vérifier pendant la nuit avant de partir
est ce qu'il ya eu des bombardements
quelles routes sont sécuritaires ou pas
jusqu'où on peut aller quel endroit sans
sont sécuritaires pour nous et c'est
donc lui qui s'occupait de saône où on
avait des connaissances assez peut-être
superficielle de ce qui se passait quand
on le disait comme tout le monde les les
détails de ces opérations là mais lui
avait des contacts avec quelqu'un
montréal aussi qui s'occupe de la
sécurité et donc je pense que c'est
assez utile et quand on était par
exemple dans le petit village d'origine
qui était tout près de la ligne de front
on était à peu près à 4,5 km de la ligne
de front et que ça bombarde est dans le
village quand on était là c'était quand
même pratique de voir avec lui parce que
quand tu avais quand un obus tomber je
le regardais en est on venu évaluer la
distance ok stade du kilomètre ou pas
donc c'est quelqu'un quand même qui est
formée militairement c'est un ancien
militaire en fait mais qui n'est pas
armé mais qui pouvait nous conseiller
sur ce qu'il fallait faire ou pas donc
j'ai trouvé que c'était utile je pense
que ça rassure tout le monde ça nous
rassure nous les équipes sur le terrain
ça rassure aussi nos patrons qu'il faut
ici puis qui s'inquiètent pour nous donc
finalement je trouve que c'est quand
même quelque chose qui coûte très cher
qui mais qui vaut la peine je crois pour
nous rassurer il ya michel cadieux de
carleton sur mer qui pose la question à
vous deux il se demande comment on fait
pour s'assurer de ne pas être manipulé
en temps de guerre parce que de la
propagande reçu de la propagande
ukrainienne on est exposé à tout ce qui
est sur les réseaux sociaux comme tout
le monde parce qu'on a des méthodes des
façons travail et amara pour s'assurer
d'être peut-être moins manipulés mais
nous a été on est manipulée constamment
et puis non seulement on les manipule et
on ne va pas donner le choix le jour
même encore une fois j'étais en ondes
avec céline le jour même où la guerre
est tout le temps en ont ensemble la
nuit
mais la nuit après le discours de
poutine ont eu des alertes ou les
journalistes étrangers locaux ça
s'appelle censure de guerre et ça nous
disait à partir de maintenant voici les
règles ne peut pas appeler ça une une
guerre faudrait invasion invasion
ressort très élevé des termes précis
donc une opération spéciale mais après
c'est eu d'autres termes donc avant de
devenir une loi et c'est une censure
donc on nous manipule est plus on nous
obligeait à utiliser des termes et par
la suite je veux dire ce qui a été
difficile pour nous c'est que pour avoir
de l'accès à l'information en mai en ce
moment avec ce que l'armée russe fait
pour les accompagner comme on le fait
avec l'armée ukrainienne aussi on nous
impose une censure une ligne éditoriale
avec laquelle on peut pas vivre qu'on
peut pas être qu'on peut pas accepter
donc on fait plus de voyages avec
l'armée russe parce que c'est ça nous
enlève complètement la liberté de presse
dont ont joui et ensuite la manipulation
se fait auprès de la population pour
avec la propagande heureusement moi moi
depuis que j en russie depuis quatre ans
il ya de la manipulation tout le temps
oui moi je suis conditionné à la décoder
ou à la à l'utiliser pour expliquer pour
moi la russie est comme elle est
pourquoi les gens pensent
comme ils pensent mais aussi aussi
manipulé par l'armée ukrainienne vous on
a beaucoup de sympathie en ce moment
pour les uns que les ukrainiens seraient
pays en guerre dans un pays où il se
passe des choses horribles mais de la
même façon je suis bombardés
d'informations c'est peut-être pas un
terme à utiliser mais
constamment sollicité par l'armée russe
l'armée ukrainienne une machine des
formations efficaces y est assez près
strass merci à qu'il peut pas faire
confiance les yeux fermés les gens
pensent peut-être que tout ce qui sort
de la bouche des ukrainiens on le prend
pour du mais pas du tout donc on on est
sollicité on est manipulée c'est à nous
de voir quelles informations sont
vérifiées et vérifiables
oui parce que en ukraine une guerre
d'image qui se joue
continuellement ils sont très très fort
là dessus les ukrainiens mais c'est vrai
que pour avoir accès à l'armée il
craignait c'est extrêmement difficile
l'armée ukrainienne et le gouvernement
ukrainien ne donne pas de 2 chiffres par
exemple sur les pertes et craignait les
pertes militaires les pertes civiles
donc tout ça est gardé très secret pour
avoir accès à l'art mais ils commencent
à ouvrir un petit peu mais au début du
conflit c'était impossible d'avoir des
images de près des côtes des soldes des
militaires etc maintenant ils acceptent
d'amener certains journalistes dans les
tranchées mais c'est très c'est très
circonscrit et c'est très réglementé
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas montrer où
ils sont alors il faut faire très
attention donc on filme absolue juste
les soldats eux-mêmes c'est ça qu'on a
le droit de donner et c'est assez court
donc ils veulent montrer c'est très
difficile par exemple moi j'ai essayé
d'aller tourner dans un hôpital
militaire pour voir les blessés etc
c'est extrêmement difficile ça se fait
mais ça demande énormément de travail
lent demande ressources aussi de temps
pour pouvoir le faire parce qu'ils sont
très frileux parce qu'ils savent que ça
se retrouve sur les réseaux sociaux ils
veulent garder le moral des non
seulement des troupes mais aussi le
moral de la population il faut que la
population continue de se mobiliser dans
ce conflit là le fait depuis le début et
c'est admirable la façon dont ils font
mais ils ont besoin de garder la
population mobilisée j'avais juste avant
de quitter la halle à la frontière de
l'ilc rennes quand la guerre a commencé
nous on a voulu parce qu'on voyait déjà
qu'ils avaient des pertes de soldats
allaient filmé près d'un hôpital où on
disait on nous disait qu'il rapatriait
les soldats déjà blessé on nous dit vous
allez vous faire tabasser vous allez
vous faire agresser donc il ya des
choses qu'on ne peut plus encore raconté
en russie et onu manipule pour nous
amener vers d'autres informations allez
plutôt voir tel tente militaire où on
les soigne mon histoire par la bonne
histoire un petit bandage donc le
contrôle de l'information fait partie
des jackson un des plus grands défis
dans ce genre de couverture quand on
travaille en zone de guerre ou à
l'étranger même qu'on parle pas la
langue locale ont fait appel à des
fixeurs jargon journalistique donc b
soit des journalistes locaux qui nous
aide à nous orienter ou à parler la
langue et traduits ou alors des simples
citoyens qui sont débrouillards qui
offrent leurs services
céline comment ça s'est passé pendant
votre couverture sur place est ce que
parce qu'évidemment les journalistes
locaux ou les fictions locaux et y vivre
la guerre ce sont des ukrainiens ils
sont confrontés à quelque chose d'encore
plus des motifs qu'un journaliste qui
s'en va faire son travail comment
c'était de travailler avec votre fiction
sur place alors nous on avait un jeune
fixeur de 21 ans qui s'appelle i lya qui
avait travaillé avec des collègues avant
à la vive et donc on a retrouvé en
arrivant en ukraine et ce n'est donc pas
un journaliste du tout c'était un site
un étudiant en philosophie en fait qui
avait aidé lui c'était son effort de
guerre donc de faire de la traduction
pour des journalistes étrangers parce
qu'il parlait très bien l'anglais mais
et nous comme journaliste quand on
arrive en général on essaie de
travailler avec des fictions qui sont
peut-être plus expérimenté des fois
qu'ils sont des fois des journalistes
locaux eux-mêmes comme je disais et ça
c'est ça nous aide énormément parce
qu'ils peuvent nous dirigent et nous
suggérer des sujets etc ils y arrêtaient
pas c'était pas sa force donc un moment
donné on se retrouve à zaporijia et là
les gens commencent à sortir on
attendait un convoi toute une journée de
rescapés de lusine d'azov talent c'était
le premier corridor humanitaire qui
avaient été organisées et les gens on ne
savait pas trop où il était en fait
parce que ça a pris énormément de temps
pour qu'il sorte de lusine d'assaut ce
talent qui passent tous les barrages
russe parce qu'un avait 26 sur le chemin
où il faisait fouillés et interrogés où
c'était assez pénible et donc finalement
ils arrivent à zaporijia où on était
mais il y avait énormément de
journalistes étrangers donc quand ça
s'est produit bien évidemment tous les
journalistes se sont précipités pour
essayer de parler à ces gens c'est pas
très franc c'est assez c'est un peu
indécent finalement mais bon c'est notre
façon de travailler et il ya des on l'a
dit contrainte de temps et c est là
notre fiction lui était en retrait puis
là il s'est mis à nous engueuler en fait
dire mais là pouvait pas faire ça ces
gens là ils ont souffert peut pas leur
sauter dessus comme ça mais c'est s'est
enrayée puisque vous faites et où
puis-je et théologien mme elliott c'est
notre travail tout ça mais ça m'a
vraiment donné une leçon d'humilité en
fait après sur le coup j'étais un petit
peu un petit peu surprise mais après je
me suis dit mais oui mais lui il a 21
ans c'est sa ville il vient d'une ville
juste à côté qui s'appelle ni pro c'est
la première fois qu'ils voient la
destruction comme ça dans sa ville parce
qu'ils étaient parvenus depuis il a
travaillé avec nous il était plus plus à
l'ouest et là en plus lui il comprend ce
que l'émotion de ces gens là
et donc c'est vrai qu'il faut se
rappeler que lui il vit comme le reste
de la population ce conflit là mais dans
sa chair et dans son sang donc on avait
d'ailleurs une question de rose marquis
de la sarre justement ce propos les qui
se demandaient ce que dans un contexte
où tous les journalistes internationaux
cherchent à travailler sur la même
histoire dense convenance que si les
rescapés de mario paul il y aurait pas
matière à contribuer à collaborer
davantage entre les réseaux pour avoir
moins de journalistes qui se rendent sur
le parler aux mêmes personnes d'avoir
moins de caméramans bref de de mettre en
commun la recherche et les ressources
pour pâques et 200 personnes qui veulent
parler à la même pas au madame qui
revient de mario police que ça serait
une façon de travailler qui serait
possible c'est très difficile parce
qu'il ya d'abord et les médias de
partout dans le monde la question de
langue il ya des japonais des espagnols
d al jazeera les médias américains et
c'est donc c'est difficile on a tous des
contraintes différentes aussi les heures
de tombée différentes donc je pense que
c'est possible dans beaucoup
d'événements c'est ce sont les grandes
agences qui peuvent tourner vers terre
on peut penser afp on peut penser à ces
grands
ces grandes chaînes qui vont produire
des images et du son pour nous qu'on va
utiliser par exemple ici quand on est
ici on a accès à ces à ces images d'
agences mais quand on est sur le terrain
on veut tous faire notre propre histoire
mais ce qu'on a fait cette fois là c'est
qu'on a fait avec tout le monde ce
reportage ce jour là parce que c'était
ça la nouvelle mais on est resté le
lendemain on a retrouvé des gens
on a pu parler à des réfugiés beaucoup
plus calmement suite et on a essayé de
faire notre travail plus humainement et
plus en profondeur après quoi la mara il
voudrait quelque chose sans mal des fois
de les traiter la caméra et micro devant
les gens qui viennent de souffrir de
subir des pertes c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on aime faire l' on veut les écouter
on a beaucoup d'empathie moi c'est un
peu c'est quelqu'un très des motifs très
émotive aussi moi j'aurais jamais
insensible et j'ai toujours mal au
ventre des fois et puis je lis j'ai
toujours un peu ce sentiment de honte
dont kylie à vous reprocher quand on
n'est pas trop agressif c'est notre
métier nous on veut rapporter ça et puis
on travaille pour la télé il nous faut
des images si je pouvais mettre en
retrait prend des notes et pas pour
agresser mais pas imposer ça à des gens
on est conscient de ça si jamais à part
plaisir qu on le fait on le fait parce
que parce qu'on doit on doit ramener ces
informations là et les gens sont
généreux je sais pas céline sont très
généreux ils le font et mais je pense
qu'en ukraine aussi les gens réalisent
que c'est important qu'ils nous parlent
parce qu'ils savent l'importance de la
couverture qui se fait dans le monde et
moi souvent les gens m'ont dit après une
entrevue pas toujours dans ces
conditions là mais ils m'ont dit on
merci d'être leur merci parce que c'est
important on veut que le monde sache ce
que la russie fait chine et pour eux
c'est important tamara vous travaillez
avec une équipe russe évidemment aussi
parce qu'on parlait tout à l'heure du
fait qu soeur de céline qui est
ukrainien qui vit sa danse avant dans
ses tripes vous avez une équipe russe
aussi qui vit un conflit déclenché par
la propre pays comment comment ça se
passait pour eux derrière la caméra ce
que nous on voyait pas quand la russie
décidé d'attaquer mais je pense que les
premiers jours céleste est est la
surprise et je peux dire la honte je
pense que leurs sentiments par rapport à
la guerre leur appartient et puis c'est
de plus en plus difficile d'en parler
publiquement aussi
moi je peux vous témoigner moi je
continue à travailler en toute
transparence avec mon caméraman russe
alex et avec qui je fais le tour des
pays limitrophes avec je suis allé en
moldavie en georgie en roumanie alexei
qui travaille pour le canada depuis 28
ans et 20 ans
très conne elle travaille en est qui et
avec qui on vit des moments assez assez
assez durs c'est pas facile d'être russe
en ce moment à l'extérieur de la russie
ça vient avec beaucoup de préjugés c'est
normal s'y attendait le passeport russe
et porte un poids je donne un exemple on
est allé tourner des enfants dans une
école ukrainienne mais en roumanie on a
établi une petite école pour les
ukrainiens et les petits parle heureuse
parce qu'ils viennent du sud de
l'ukraine de dessin même si on leur
apprend l'ukrainien et quand ils
attendaient à l'excès tournée parlait en
russe tout de suite mais les russes lui
demandent à leurs professeurs mais les
russes que ce qu'il fait c'est un
réflexe on voulait les tournées on est
allé tourner sur une base militaire de
l'otan en roumanie m'ont dit clairement
votre caméraman même un peu les pieds
sur la base militaire on ne prend pas de
russes sur une base on fait des
exercices de dissuasion contre la russie
est ce que c'est clair ok mais c'est une
nouvelle mais c'est une nouvelle réalité
il un visa pour l'europe sait pas on
n'essaie pas de on est on est en toute
légalité c'est un poids à porter pour
ceux qui sont encore en russie
il ya beaucoup d'anxiété en russie on a
de plus en plus de difficultés à savoir
ce que les gens pensent et comment les
gens vivent cette guerre mais moi je
sais qu'il ya une insécurité financière
et une sécurité sociale pour l'avenir et
puis nous vous me demandez mon équipe on
a appris hier qu'on était obligé de
fermer le bureau advitam et pour de bon
ton pour l'instant et ça c'est
bouleversant parce que c'est leur vie
c'est leur gagne pain c'est là la raison
d'être de façade en tout cas et parce
qu'on ait lieu des employés de
radio-canada sur place qu'ils ne peuvent
plus travailler qui ne pourront plus
très bientôt
qu'ils nous ont été fidèles céline était
le cas l'année j'arrivais en 81 la
première fois chez al islah en 92 mais
non qu'il ya des employés une employée
en particulier irina mednikova à l'été
là c'était notre administratrice notre
mère à tous et elle était là à
l'ouverture du bureau de télévision quoi
et avant ça je pense qu'elle était même
là avant je ressens radio et d'une
efficacité parce que la bureaucratie
russe s'il fallait qu'on s'y consacre en
tant que journaliste on pourrait jamais
à leur nom elle fait ça à temps plein
alors chez le notaire trois fois par
jour parce qu'il faut tout notari une
durée très lourde en russie et sans elle
on pourrait pas être là et on perdrait
beaucoup de temps d'un point de vue très
pratico pratiques qui y vont grenier de
la malbaie qui veut savoir conserver
dans une zone de conflit comme ça
comment on fait pour payer est ce qu'on
prend de la monnaie locale est ce qu'on
arrive avec une tonne de rod argent
américain est ce qu'on prend encore les
cartes de crédit commence à friser
craignait l'ukraine est un pays très
moderne tout le monde paye avec son
téléphone donc c'est là dessus ça marche
d'une carte de crédit fonctionne et tout
ça mais on se promène quand même comme
dans beaucoup de pays du monde avec
beaucoup de dollars américains pour
payer certaines personnes payer des
salaires partie plus facile à ses
préfaces il ya martin provost de beloeil
tamara qui veut savoir comment se
sentent les couples mixtes parce
qu'évidemment des russes qui sont mariés
avec des ukrainiens et versement des
ukrainiennes qui vivent avec des russes
parce que cette deux peuples qui sont
très près historiquement l'un l'autre je
pense que vous avez eu l'occasion d'en
rencontrer en russie ou dans les pays
visés vont se craignent et voilà ce qu
on fait pas cette direction là parce que
l'ukrainien et reus et le russe et
ukrainien aussi parce qu ils sont nés
une époque où l'ukraine faisait partie
de l'union soviétique mais c'est sûr que
oui bon ukrainien et ethnique si on veut
dire comme ça il ya beaucoup de coups de
couples mixtes moi dans mon j'ai
beaucoup de couples mixtes européens
russes je connaissais des ukrainiens des
gens qui ont quitté en fait la réussite
de plus clair la guerre a éclaté
jeu j'ai rencontré des gens chez qui se
confient la a créé des tensions énormes
il ya une espèce de clash de jeu de deux
générations brisure générationnelle des
ans des gens plus jeunes mais pas si
jeunes des coupes de 40 50 ans dont les
parents refusent
d'abandonner la ligne du kremlin et des
gens que j'ai rencontrés en georgie par
exemple qui ont pris la fuite et dont
les parents leur ont prévenu
c'est fini vous êtes des traîtres parce
que vous quittez la rue si vous prenez
les petits enfants avec vous pour aller
refaire votre vie ailleurs
vous n'êtes pas fidèle à votre patrie
c'est c'est dur à voir et puis moi c'est
ça qui me fâche de pu être la bosse et
toutes ces questions auxquelles
j'aimerais répondre je peux plus je peux
je peux plus faire me faire cette
opinion que j'avais ce regard pur que
j'avais sur la la la réflexion des
russes en ce moment j'en suis privée
avec eux quand on était sur le terrain
juste rajouter quelque chose c'est on a
rencontré beaucoup de familles quand on
parlait à des gens par exemple après
près d'un immeuble qui venait d'être
détruit par un missile
les gens nous nous et quand je leur
demandais ce que vous êtes fâchés est ce
que vous êtes en colère contre vladimir
poutine et seuls les gens nous disaient
oui on est en colère qu'on va devenir
fonctionnel et encore plus en colère
contre mon frère ma soeur pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont en russie et qu'il ne nous
croit pas je le range viennent leur
envoyer la vidéo de notre maison qui est
détruite et ils me disent que c'est pas
vrai donc la réponse venait comme ça
donc les des familles très proche des
gens un des frères des soeurs donc ceux
qui sont en russie il ne croit pas que
les ukrainiens qui sont quand même de
leur propre famille leur explique donc
la propagande en russie elle est très
forte moi j'ai vécu cette scène où
j'étais prêt rôle entendu en début
d'émission où j'étais à la frontière
près de kharkiv et il ya une dame qui
attendait parce que l'armée russe avait
complètement monopolisé son quartier se
servait de son quartier pour tirer sur
harkis qui était à 40 km elle était au
téléphone avec sa soeur qui était caché
dans son sous-sol à kharkhiv et qui lui
racontait ce qui lui arrivait donc les
familles ukrainiennes ont la famille en
russie les familles en russie on la
famille en ukraine et c'est ce qui est
complètement absurde il ya une question
qui vient de facebook de jean plamondon
qui vient tout juste d'une la pause et
quelques minutes qui se demandent ce
qu'est la désinformation en russie est à
ce point généralisée qu'il est
impossible maintenant d'envisager que
poutine puis s'être renversée soit par
son armée soit par ses proches soit par
la population tamara une question
tellement tellement difficile
renversé je vous dis renversé par qui
renversait par la population par ces
jeunes qu'on a vus par milliers depuis
les deux dernières années en fait depuis
le retour de laval nick avait vraiment
énergisé ce mouvement anti poutine parce
que c'était pas un mouvement pro navalni
c'est surtout un mouvement anti vladimir
c'est ce qui le réveiller alexine aval
des carrières venu je parle de
l'opposant bien sûr quand il est revenu
d'allemagne et ces jeunes là qui sont
vraiment déterminés sont partis de
russie sont ok ils ont par d'être enrôlé
dans l'armée on parle de la mobilisation
générale ils veulent ils se croient plus
utile à l'extérieur de la russie
d'ailleurs j'ai mon caméraman qui est à
vilnius aujourd'hui qui couvre la
première conférence organisée par ces
gens en exil s'appelle libérons la
libérer la russie et qui commence à
planter peut-être les graines d'un
éventuel mouvement mais à l'intérieur de
la russie pour des raisons à cause la
propagande et parce que les vrais
militants ne sont plus là non plus le
droit d'exister vladimir poutine avait
préparé le terrain avant de déclencher
la guerre en ukraine il avait pris il
avait eu recours à des mesures de
répression qu'on avait jamais vu durant
ces vingt années au pouvoir en
bannissant des candidats en bannissant
l'opposition donc tout le monde est
parti donc si j'avais une question
justement à ce sujet-là de stéphane
tessier de montréal qui dit donc l'exode
elle se poursuit des jeunes des cerveaux
entre autres ceux qui pensent que ça va
être difficile de faire sa vie en russie
il y en a beaucoup plus ont quitté déjà
oui mais juste pour finir la loi donc le
soulèvement populaire moi je le vois pas
parce que ceux qui étaient prêts à le
faire sont plus là mais peut-être que je
me trompe là où on vous regarde et c'est
là mais c'est les généraux vous savez
les coups d'état viennent souvent de la
lesbienne de l'armée est ce que l'armée
un jour va se retourner contre lui
problème la demi-heure poutine gouverne
seul camp quand quelqu'un gouverne seul
le pays va être victime de ses bons
coups de ses erreurs pour l'instant je
ne vois pas ce scénario là pour ce qui
est de l'exode elle se poursuit sauf que
les piles les options pour les russes
sont pas énormes
tous les pays d'europe pour lesquels il
faut en dessous on appelle un visa
schengen mais bon c'est un visa qui nous
permet d entrer avec pour un certain
nombre de jours
ça fait partie des sanctions c'est plus
possible donc un russe qui veut aller en
finlande un russe qui veut aller 1
en france c'est fini on émet plus de ces
des gens qui doivent se tourner vers des
pays comme l'arménie la géorgie
l'azerbaïdjan la turquie
dubaï il ya beaucoup moi je suis j'ai dû
passer par dubaï quand j'ai quitté la
russie et tout est traduit en russe dans
les hôtels ou des jeunes et sur fip
parce que l'afflux et massif mais les
riches
sur la côte d'azur et qui peuvent plus
être voilà qui sont à dubaï parce qu'ils
sont allés ranger leur argent ils ont
sorti à une panique m le vol que j'ai
pris pour dubaï on l'avait réservée par
ce que il était plein à craquer avait
une liste parce que les gens voulaient
aller vers dubaï en arrivant à dubaï
c'était comme si j'étais à moscou à
l'aéroport n'y avait que des russes
autour de moi que des russes à l'hôtel
que des russes pour tout cela nous est
allé à butcher banlieue de kiev un mois
après la destruction de la ville les
crimes de guerre de guerre qui ont été
perpétrés sur place qu'est ce qui vous a
marqué
le traumatisme des gens encore un mois
un mois après parce que quand on est
arrivé à bout de champ on savait pas
trop à quoi s'attendre parce
qu'évidemment les journalistes sont
ailleurs maintenant donc nous on est
arrivé on s'est dit moi je me suis dit
s'il faut que j'aille quelques parents
jouer à lille a d'abord parce que c'est
juste au nord de kiev et quand on est
arrivé on a réalisé que pour beaucoup de
familles le traumatisme est encore là
parce que les corps qui ont été
découverts un mois avant il y en a
encore beaucoup qui sont à la morgue
parce que y ait des enquêtes qui se font
sur ces crimes de guerre donc qui sont
examinées en examen à la mort de boudhha
à peu près 15 corps par jour et on pense
qu'il ya eu plusieurs centaines de morts
à abuja donc les familles sont toujours
là dans des dents dans la petite mort le
petit à côté du petit hôpital et ils
attendent de recevoir le corps ils
savent que peut-être que c'est lui parce
qu'il faut les identifier les corps qui
sont énormément
détruit enfin qui sont en morceaux donc
il faut les identifier avant il faut
réparer un peu les corps avant les avant
de les remettre aux familles donc un
mois après on enterre encore les morts à
bout de champ mais c'est des morts qui
sont là depuis longtemps donc le
traumatisme de la population est très
fort la destruction bien sûr et puis
c'est passé dans cette banlieue de kiev
donc au tout début de la guerre des
choses qui se passe ailleurs mais pas à
la même échelle en fait on n'a pas
retrouvé mais mac arrive on n'a pas
retrouvé le même genre d'occupation
aussi brutale aussi violente que ce
qu'il ya eu au début de ce conflit ce
qui ce qui est un peu les terribles en
fait pour ces gens là quoi parce qu'en
plus par la suite la l'ukraine a pu
repousser les forces russes dont qui à
la fois une fierté d'être libéré et la
vie commence à reprendre son cours
normal mais il ya aussi encore cet
énorme traumatisme que quand on arrive
face à face à une femme qui pleure dans
la rue et qui est en train de mettre des
fleurs sur le coin de la rue et on lui
parle on lui dit qu'est ce qui vous est
arrivé elle timmins c'est là que mon
mari a été abattu
devant mes yeux quand ils l'ont abattu
d'une balle parce qu'à bout de ça aussi
il faut dire que la plupart des victimes
donc ne sont pas mortes à cause des
bombardements de la guerre des combats
ils ont été abattus par les russes il y
avait d un bataillon tchétchène qui
était assez brutale et donc cette femme
elle a vu son mari mourir à la pol droit
de ramasser les corps à ce moment là
elle a été enfermée chez elle ses terres
et chez elle pendant un mois elle
voulait mourir parce que c'était le
grand amour de sa vie c'est une femme
qui est assez jeune et
il a fallu qu'elle attend d'un mois à
l'as vécu tout ce temps dans son sous
sol pour pouvoir aller chercher le corps
de son mari l'a tous les jours elle va
mettre des fleurs elle a pu l'enterrer
maintenant mais tous les jours elle va
mettre des fleurs donc c'est sûr que
c'est le traumatisme qui va rester cette
guerre va laisser des traces sur une
population entière ça a été tellement
brutale comme en tchétchénie par exemple
quand je suis retourné en tchétchénie où
il s'est passé la même chose
quelqu'un m'avait dit ben oui maintenant
c'est calme poutine peut dire que c'est
très calme ici c'est calme comme un
cimetière parce que tout le monde est
mort ou réprimées en ce moment oui c'est
dur arthuis très très vieux parlant de
souffrances on une auditrice jeunes
iront prix qui est âgé de 10 ans j'ai
demandé comment les enfants vont en
ukraine s'il y en a qui souffrent comme
elle se comporte je pense vous avez eu
l'occasion d'en rencontrer c'est le
nouveau en plus les enfants dans ce
conflit là je pense que ça dépend de ce
qu'ils ont vécu on l'a vu cet exode
massif dès le début de la guerre parce
que les ukrainiens se sont dépêchés de
de sortir la plupart des enfants ce
qu'il pouvait on les a on les a sortis
sont allés s'installer ailleurs dans des
pays vous en avez rencontré au
remaniement roumanie mais il y en a eu
beaucoup en pologne et tout ça où ils
sont organisés c'est sûr qu'un
traumatisme de quitter celle de quitter
leur maison de se retrouver dans un pays
en guerre et tous mais ça dépend ce
qu'ils ont vécu par exemple nous on a
parlé à un jeune de 14 ans qui sortait
de l'usiné d'azf talent vova son père
est un colonel du régiment azoff donc il
est sorti et la première chose qui nous
a dit c'était j'avais pas vu le soleil
depuis deux mois ça faisait deux mois
qui vivaient dans les souterrains de
cuisine et j'ai on lui a demandé
qu'est-ce que comment ça se passait tout
ça et dire j'ai mangé beaucoup de gruau
alors il mangeait du gruau depuis un
mois donc c'est sûr que c'est billy
bombardement jeudi ils ont été bombardés
constamment donc pour eux c'est terrible
mais il ya quand même beaucoup d'efforts
pour essayer de maintenir un semblant de
vie pour les enfants et craignait les
ukrainiens
puissant très très proches de leur
enfant et puis c'est comment on sent
bien que c'est la prunelle mais les
enfants vit plus sur le dans le moment
que nous que les adultes ont commencé ce
que j'ai vu partout j'ai vu diffusion
les deux tournées aussi a riga en
lettonie
il ya des clones on essaie de les
protéger mais c'est sûr qu'il ya des
services psychologiques que c'est pas
aussi faciles à repérer que chez un
adulte parce que il ya un instinct de
survie chez l'enfant mais nous on a vu
des enfants qui qui ont mal parce qu'ils
voient leurs parts en pleurer c'est ça
qui me disait le lion ne présentait un
reportage cette semaine les mêmes petits
garçons dans la classe qui dessinaient
chaque fois que la propre passé caché
son son son dessin en dessous ton bureau
il a fini par nous le montre ips et la
tête de vladimir poutine en sang et ils
disent mais pourquoi eddy papes savent
sa prof le chic à n'est pas ce que
disent pourquoi faire ça même si bon on
comprend d'où ça vient cette haine
envers leurs verres vladimir poutine est
dit mon père est encore là bas mon père
doit se battre ma mère pleure tous les
soirs ma maison a été bombardée donc
c'est sûr que ça va j'ai marqué pour
toujours mais dans ce qui est beau quand
on va dans des écoles ou qu'en venant
des centres où on les occupe c'est quand
on prend soin d'eux mais c'est pas le
cas pour tous les enfants ouais c'est
l'aide on a reçu beaucoup de questions
concernant les victimes de viols en
ukraine c'est un des crimes de guerre
qu'ils aient perpétré dans toutes les
gares malheureusement ce que vous avez
réussi à rencontrer alors faire parler
de ça c'est très difficile parce que
d'abord ça s'est passé
dans la région de kiev où j'étais
surtout ça s'est passé avant que
j'arrive et c'est ces femmes-là ses
victimes maintenant ont été évacuées
elles sont elles ont quitté le pays pour
la plupart mais c'est un crime qui est
en train d'être documenté de façon très
précise et on se rend compte à quel
point quand les russes sont arrivés dans
la
nuque rennes ils ont instauré non pas
seulement un régime d'occupation comme
ça peut se faire dans certains pays ou
dans certaines conditions mais ils ont
installé un régime de terreur il est
donc ce que disent les avocats ukrainien
qui font les qui font les enquêtes en ce
moment c'est que ça a été utilisé comme
arme de guerre c'est à dire qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de viol ils ont documenté des
viols collectifs et des viols perpétrés
souvent devant les familles devant les
proches donc de façon non pas seulement
à blesser ou à humilier et la personne
qui était violée il ya eu des viols
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants pas
seulement deux femmes et donc c'est pas
seulement la personne qui est visé mais
c'est la communauté autour c'est donc
détruire briser la résistance en
instaurant un régime de terreur et en
parce que parce que les gens qui
regardent ces viols ils se sentent
impuissants se sentent coupables parce
que ils ont pas réussi à protéger cette
personne et et beaucoup aussi après on
peur alors ils veulent se se protéger
protéger leur fille protéger leurs
femmes et donc il ya vraiment ça
vraiment un impact sur toute la
communauté pour briser cette résistance
joan beall d'eau de trois pistoles
pardon qui se demandaient ce que ces
femmes là qu'ils ont été violés ou ses
hommes l'audace qui en effectivement
aussi sont ostracisés par leur
communauté comme on l'a vu dans d'autres
conflits en république démocratique du
congo entre autres ce qu'ils sont jugés
par leurs propres populations
je n'ai pas senti dead mais je n'ai pas
comme je dis j'ai pas pu parler à des
femmes qui ont été violées directement
mais je n'ai pas senti dans les
commentaires que j'ai au contraire j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
soutien pour ces femmes là et il faut
dire aussi que pour ces femmes-là elles
sont en pleine guerre il ya une
occupation très brutale et ce qu'on m'a
dit c'est que très souvent quand on
avait le témoignage de ces femmes là le
viol ne venait pas au début c'est
d'abord la violence de l'occupation le
fait qu'elles ont perdu leur maison le
fait qu'elles ont été bombardés le fait
qu'elles ont dû survivre dans des
conditions épouvantables parce qu'ils
ont dû se cacher ils ont souvent été
contraint de vivre dans des caves sans
eau sans nourriture par par l'armée
russe il avait dès qu'ils sortaient dans
la rue il y avait des snipers qui
tiraient sur les gens et tout donc ça a
été une terreur pendant un mois donc
c'est d'abord ça qu'elle raconte ça
prend beaucoup de temps avant que la
personne parle du viol comme si
d'abord il ya une honte parler de ça
c'est très difficile pour elle comme
pour toutes les victimes de viol dans
d'en parler mais c'est aussi parce que
c'est quelque chose qui s'ajoutent à une
toute une série de l'événement qui font
souffrir ces femmes là et donc c'est
très difficile de leur parler mais j'ai
senti quand même un certain soutien
même si il n'y a pas tant d'organismes
de soutien pour les femmes je parle
d'avant la guerre on y voit l oms l oms
l'avortement est légal quand même en
ukraine beaucoup maintenant sont en
pologne et la pologne à une des
législations les plus restrictives
d'europe sur l'avortement donc ça crée
des problèmes je lance pour les femmes
chrétiennes qui se retrouvent en pologne
mais en ukraine je pense qu'elles ont eu
le soutien ainsi pas dans des sociétés
par exemple musulmane c'est très
extrêmement difficile pour les femmes
parce qu'elles sont souvent rejetés par
leur famille mais jay je n'ai pas senti
mais comme je dis je n'ai pas parlé des
femmes directement regardons un peu vers
l'avenir tamara on a reçu une question
de martin la haye de gatineau qui se
demandent dans l'éventualité d'une
victoire de l'ukraine ou d'un retrait de
la russie sans gains territoriaux claire
quelles pourraient être les conséquences
à ce que lis ce que les russes vont
accepter de perdre cette guerre losc
ellipses séparatiste pro-russe dans une
base vont en subir les conséquences
comment vous voyez les prochains mois ça
c'est la décision d'un homme et c'est
vladimir poutine et on sait pas on sait
toujours pas qu'est-ce qui va définir
pour lui une victoire une défaite
l'admirent poutine a créé un univers
tellement parallèle en russie qui le
contrôlent donc il va pouvoir dire dans
ce même univers qu'est ce qui est une
victoire et qu'est-ce qui est une
défaite offre est pour l'instant l'on
sent que la gare stagne moi je n'étais
pas sur le terrain en ukraine mais on a
des journalistes ont continué à suivre
tout ce qui se passe à distance et j'ai
l'impression que une espèce de
stagnation et nous notre crainte c'est
qu'elles font qu'on ne faut pas arrêter
d'en parler pour passer une guerre
d'usure sugar qui s'installe à partir de
quel moment
on va pouvoir déclarer une défaite ou
une
une victoire mais je pense pas que c'est
dans l'est dans un futur très rapproché
il ya encore des négociations de paix
mais c'est pas vraiment des négociations
de paix ces des échanges de prisonniers
c'est des négociations pour pour pour
régler certaines questions entre la
russie et l'ukraine mais il n'y a pas de
je ne vois pas dans les prochaines
semaines en tout cas une fin à ce
conflit mais peu importe la fin la
demi-heure poutine peut contrôler le
message là me trouver une manière de
dire que gagner quelque chose auprès
d'une population à qui le manipulent de
toute façon qui est compact convaincu à
100% parce que je suis pas là et
j'arrive plus à avoir une lecture
fidèles de ce que les gens pensent mais
qui semble avoir convaincu qu'il fallait
agressé l'ukraine pour anéantir un
mouvement nazi qui menaçait la russie
avec l'aide des états unis
ça c'est un fait établi pour beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de russes quand de
créer cette narrative bhl mais on va
contrôler le ménage comparaison dans le
fond on va contrôler à 3 à mon avis le
message par rapport à qu'est-ce qu'on a
gagné qu est ce qu on a perdu c'est sûr
qu'il renoncera pas au donbass l'oeil le
mario paul
détruites céline disait on sait pas
c'est probablement dans la banlieue de
kiev que les atrocités les pires parce
qu'on a pu les vérifier
on sait qu'on pourra jamais vérifier ce
qui s'est passé à mario paul c'est eux
qui contrôlent avec beaucoup de
difficultés apparemment parce qu'encore
beaucoup de gens qui sont pas des pro
russe il ya des pro russe part
dans l'est dans les régions dans l'est
de l'ukraine mais des gens qui vont se
révolter ou actuellement donc cesser
cette guerre là moi je vous envoie pas
encore la fin mai sims et vladimir
poutine et ses généraux qui contrôle et
détermineront qu'est ce qu'il est pour
eux une victoire une défaite et le mot
défaite ne sortira jamais de sa bouche
céline comment vous voyez les prochains
mois parce que quand même une influence
de ce conflit le bien au delà de
l'ukraine et de la russie seulement on a
vu ce qui s'est passé à l'otan entre
autres on a des nouveaux pays qui
veulent adhérer à cette défense de
l'alliance du traité de l'atlantique
nord comment vous voyez les prochains
mois mais quand vous parlez aux
ukrainiens ils n'ont aucun doute que ce
qu'ils vont gagner cette guerre il
saisit croire croit il y croit il
aussi qu'ils n'ont pas le choix c'est à
dire que ils ne peuvent pas laisser
vladimir poutine l'a gagné mais c'est
sûr que les pertes c'est cette bataille
qu'il mène elle a un prix je veux dire
c'est pour eux ils réalisent bien que ya
des villes entières qui sont détruites
ont parlé de mario pole mais karkhiv
aussi a été en partie détruite donc il
ya quand même un prix un très lourd prix
à payer mais ils sont convaincus qu'avec
l'aide qu'ils reçoivent de l'extérieur
parce que là il ya beaucoup plus d'armes
lourdes qui rentrent en ukraine mais ça
prend du temps et donc un général
ukrainien disait ben la véritable guerre
avant de dérouler un peu plus donc dans
quelques mois quoi parce que là les
armes lourdes dont est arrivé l'ukraine
va être en mesure de répondre à l'
attaque russe beaucoup plus que ce
qu'elle peut faire en ce moment parce
que le conflit qui s'est déplacé la
guerre urbaine la guérilla urbaine qui
s'est déroulée dans les régions de kiev
c'est une chose mais la guerre qui se
déroule dans le dos de basse la russie a
quand même un avantage parce qu'elle est
beaucoup plus armé a beaucoup plus
d'hommes aussi qu'ils peuvent se battre
et pour l'ukraine il faut aussi amener
tout cet armement qui rentrent
probablement par la pologne par d'autres
pays mais qui arrivent de l'ouest et il
faut le transporter pour l'instant ça
arrive quand même au compte-gouttes ça
arrive mais ça arrive au contenu sauf
que je sais pas ce qu'ils me disent
aussi les ukrainiens c'est que la russie
mène une guerre comme l emmenait en
tchétchénie ou en 1945 wastyn guerre de
tranchées avec des chars avec des
blindés avec beaucoup de soldats
qui peuvent mourir parce que ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance apparemment pour
les généraux russes alors que la
l'ukraine est beaucoup plus mobile mène
une guerre plus moderne c'est elle on ne
bat pour sa survie
sa vie pour son pays ça c'est de
l'oxygène pour les sols
céline galipeau tamar altéré sco merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous depuis
presqu'une heure maintenant c'était fort
intéressant et enrichissant merci pour
votre travail aussi que vous effectuez
pour mieux nous informer nous faire
comprendre cette guerre lauder ceux qui
ont encore des questions vous serez à la
période de questions et redit dans
quelques minutes alors ceux qui ont
encore des questions pour on voulait
poser en direct à la télé merci
énormément d'avoir été avec
c'est bien je prends maintenant quelques
secondes pour souligner le travail de
mon équipe merci d'ailleurs beaucoup à
ceux qui nous ont aidés pour cette
réalisation de facebook live en direct
sur youtube également la technique que
martin lavoie dominique que broadway
également la technique aujourd'hui il ya
la recherche en rotation cette semaine
karine guillemette geneviève gagné
jacinthe leblanc et mme guérot dufour
mathieu l'isère la réalisation c'était
geneviève gagné et dimitri qui atteint
d'autisme le rédacteur en chef de cette
émission et jean-philippe peu cheap
riani je suis alec castonguay merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous cette
semaine on se retrouve lundi
[Musique]
bravo
bonjour ici annie desrochers
[Musique]